Guys, I am not doing okay.
If I sound different to you, it is because I knew I forgot to do something.
Or like maybe many things.
But one of the things I forgot to do...
Okay, let me turn myself down.
I'm a mess right now.
My audio settings is really not good at the moment, chat.
I forgot to save my audio settings.
I saved the wrong word.
I loaded in the wrong settings.
I saved the wrong one.
So basically, I use GoXLR.
Because I'm stupid.
And GoXLR is like the baby mixing thing.
So the thing is, there are two profiles you can save.
So I saved the wrong one.
The profile I saved...
where it adjusts the volume of your stuff.
I didn't realize there are two different profiles.
I saved the one where it just gives you the set volume.
Not my mic settings.
So I was like playing around with my...
I like...
The thing is...
I didn't realize I like...
fucked up my mic settings.
Because I did...
The reason being...
Is that...
I did...
Thought about it and be like...
Oh, what if I fuck up?
Alright, I'm going to take a screenshot of my mic settings.
Just in case...
I am going to take a screenshot.
But the thing is...
I accidentally adjusted something.
On it.
On the setting.
But then I was like...
It's okay.
I'll just like...
Delete that profile.
And then like...
Copy it.
Because I already copied.
I was like...
Oh, that's okay.
I copied and pasted the profile.
So it will like...
Make sure it like...
Stays the same.
But I copied and pasted...
The volume profile.
Not the mic profile.
So I ended up not...
I ended up screenshotting.
The settings that I fucked up.
So I was just like...
I was just like...
Oh no!
So I had like...
A screenshot of like all of the mic settings.
But it's the one where I fucked it up.
I don't know which one I fucked up.
I don't know which one I adjusted.
So like...
I...
I sound so weird.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry everybody.
I hate it.
The thing is... but... but... no no no no no.
But the thing is... I still have that profile.
I'm gonna have to unplug this PC and plug in my old PC back.
So I can grab
my mic profile.
It's
good.
I had to unplug it anyway.
I have... the thing is though chat.
I have to unplug it anyway.
Because I didn't realize... the thing is... I didn't realize that...
This PC only has one SSD.
It only has one driver.
So because it only has one driver...
I have to go back to the store and add another driver.
Because I didn't realize it's only one driver.
So... yeah it's only one.
I mean it's...
It's free.
I can't complain.
The PC is literally free.
So I can't complain.
So like I have to add another driver in here.
So...
I'm not risking adding my old drivers to the new one.
Because like I don't know what fucked up in my old PC.
This is the thing.
I don't know like what it was in my old PC.
That's like...
Fucking...
Like killing my PC.
Like I don't know what type of cancer my PC has.
So like I'm worried like if I...
It's okay just like think of it like...
Think of it like I don't know something terminal.
A PC has something terminal.
And like if I bring that terminal disease into my new PC...
It's gonna spread to my new PC.
So I need to make sure.
I need...
I need to make sure that it doesn't cross paths.
Like I don't want to contaminate it.
So...
So that is why.
We need to contain it into the old body.
We can't spread it to this new PC.
Anyways sound guy.
Am I too loud?
I don't...
I don't know.
I'm using one of the default settings.
Because when I try to put it...
Okay I'll show you guys what it sounds.
When I try to put it...
When I try to put it on my old PC.
Like my default settings.
Okay let me save this one.
Because this was like the only saving grace I have.
Alright this is basically what I sound like.
With my old settings.
But oh...
I cut in and out.
Whoa.
It's...
It's not good.
.
So like...
I don't know what to do.
.
I think I'll go back.
So I don't know.
I don't know.
Now I'm back.
I'm back now.
.
That's why.
I'm a mess guys.
I'm a mess.
But at least I got my new PC before stream started.
So I win.
.
So in the end.
I win.
.
I'm sorry.
Ran into windows.
Okay.
To be fair.
I don't feel like a winner right now.
I don't.
.
To be fair chat.
I don't feel like a winner.
I feel like a mess at the moment.
.
Then we'll all have the same fate.
I'm on my new PC!
They give the Magenta Super!
Thank you!
Alright, so let me tell you the story of everything that happened today.
So like, um, it's been a long time.
By the way...
I did the file moving by an external hard drive.
I did not move... I did not move my drives.
Because I'm worried that my drivers were the issue as well.
So like, I was worried that like, I don't know, when my drivers is like, fucking...
Um, is like carrying the disease.
So like, I didn't want to move that into my new PC.
So I moved all like, the important files that I need.
Which was, okay to be fair, I also didn't...
There was so many important files.
So...
Sorry, I meant drives... guys, I'm a mess.
My brain's not working.
I meant drives.
So like, basically, I moved all my important files.
Which was like, I don't know, 600 gigabytes of stuff.
I don't know, 600 to 7...
Everything.
You know like, when you're highlighting and you're like, you highlight everything.
And you're like, everything is important.
Like, that's basically it.
So there's like, 600 gigabytes of files.
On my 1 terabyte external hard drive.
So...
So, yeah.
So I moved all of that.
And then I moved it to the new PC.
But the thing is, before I like, I was... I brought it out.
So like, you know how I always said like, guys, I cannot...
I cannot move it.
I'm worried I can't move it to my new PC.
Because I'm worried that it's not gonna fit.
Because the whole is triangular.
Well, it fits, so...
.
Guys, I couldn't believe it.
If the triangular PC fit in the square hole.
That's crazy, guys.
That was my main excuse.
That was my main excuse, guys.
And it actually fit.
Who would've thought?
Guys.
Okay, let me show you guys.
For those who don't follow me on Twitter.
So like...
This is basically...
Uh...
Alright, here.
Let me get the image out for you guys.
Oh my god, it's a big image too.
I need to resize it.
I need to resize it real quick.
Alright, so...
Here's the shape.
Here's the PC, guys.
So like...
I forgot that like...
On the side...
I could just slip it in on the side.
Instead of trying to force...
I forgot there's a giant hole on the side.
I was...
I was so focused on the two pillars in the front.
That I didn't realize that there was a hole on the side.
So...
So I could just slip it in.
So I learned something new today.
Regarding shapes.
Chat.
Is that crazy?
Alright, anyway.
So...
I slipped it off the side.
And I...
In the The In the hole...
This was one of the main reasons it took so long because I was so worried about it not fitting into the hole.
The PC case hole.
Like the PC hole.
And...
And like.
So like that's why it's been delayed for so long.
So then when I finally took it out of the box.
I was like, wait...
It actually fits!
This is one of the biggest reasons why I never unpacked the PC.
It's because I was worried it wasn't going to fit.
So I was like, going to try to figure out how to put this PC into the hole.
But look guys, it fits!
I'm so happy!
Yay!
So yes.
After putting it into the hole...
Another issue came up.
Apparently...
As I plugged everything in...
I realized there was no graphics card in there.
Because the graphics card was shipped separately.
So we got it out of the hole.
And I am scared about...
Putting graphics cards...
Into a PC.
I'm really scared about that.
Because like...
This is a very expensive free PC.
And I was like...
I already got this far...
And I don't want to break anything.
So...
Because like...
At one point I almost broke the memory stick.
Well, yeah...
Putting memory sticks into...
RAM into the graphics cards.
The other boards and stuff is so scary.
Like, when I have to do it myself.
So then, like, after that I don't like putting parts into PCs anymore.
Because I almost... I almost broke one of the RAMs.
So... so, like, it...
So because of that, I don't... I don't put parts into PCs anymore.
Because I'm worried about breaking a very expensive PC part.
Bite size.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okie dokie.
I think I'm going to go back to basic geometry.
How many sides?
It's almost... It's a triangle!
I don't know what other shape it could be.
Chat.
No.
It's definitely not a square.
Alright.
Anyway.
So, because of that, like, my... my... my dad...
My mom and dad took it to the store.
Like, one of the stores near us.
One of the PC repair stores.
And we're like, can you... And they're like, can you please put the...
Put the graphics card into the PC.
And then luckily it got done within, like, 30 minutes.
Dad brought it back home.
We put it back... We put the triangle back into the square hole.
And... And then, you know, we started booting everything up!
Yay!
It was working!
Things were, like, starting to work!
And then I... And then, like, you know, I had to install all the updates and everything.
And...
Oh, yeah.
By the way, when we removed the old PC...
When we removed the old PC from the box... from the square hole...
There was so much dust underneath.
I like how people are like, how long have you, like, known?
How long have you not cleaned your PC?
I cleaned my PC, like, I think, like, November?
Yeah, November.
That PC has... was cleaned in November.
I know it's, like, a long time since November, by the way.
But...
But it was clean!
Anyway... Anyway...
Anyway... Um...
There was so much dust underneath, though.
It was crazy.
There was, like, a clump of dust.
So my dad started vacuuming... vacuuming it all up before we put the triangle back into the square hole.
I realized there was, like, no music playing during my agony.
Anyway, let's have some happy music playing in there just to feel a little bit better about myself.
Anyway...
Um...
After...
Wait, let me...
I guess you can still...
Let me put a tiny version of this here.
Alright, so you guys can still look at chat.
Anyway!
So, after all of that...
Um...
As I was about to...
I was plugging in the... all the slots and everything.
Um...
I was plugging in all the slots and everything.
And then I realized...
Why is there only two slots for...
Why is there only two slots for monitors?
That can't be!
Like, even my old PC...
My old PC had, like, four slots for monitors.
So then I was, like, freaking out.
I was like, why is there only two slots?
Like, I was like, there's literally a 40-something in there.
I don't know which one it is.
But there's literally...
I don't know my numbers.
But there's literally a 40x in there.
Like, why?
Why could...
Is there only two holes?
And the thing is...
It's so...
My desk is, like, up against the...
My desk is, like...
Up against the...
Almost close to the wall.
But it's not up against the wall, by the way.
It's more so, like...
There's two other pillars.
There's two pillars at the end.
So it's very hard to, like...
See inside...
Like, see deeper inside...
To be like, where the fuck are the holes?
Because there's, like, two more pillars at the end.
You know?
So there's two pillars at the end...
And two pillars at the front.
So it's very hard to see...
Deeper to see where the graphics card is.
The holes for monitors.
So I had to take it out again!
And I realized...
You know?
I didn't realize this was the thing.
But there's plugs on a PC!
I was like, damn!
They plugged it!
Sorry.
But, like...
If you guys didn't know...
Like...
Newer PC...
Graphics...
Like, newer graphics cards...
Have, like, these little, like...
Dust plugs.
You know?
Like, you know what I'm talking about?
Like, they're like...
The dust plugs...
Where they cover up some of the holes.
But they don't...
So then, like...
There was like six of them.
So I had to, like...
Unplug, like...
Two of them.
And...
Don't laugh at that!
I mean, it sounds fucking weird!
MicroChat...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Prove to us that your old PC is clean.
I mean, it's clean now!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you!
Thank you for the 20 gift championships!
Anyway...
So, like...
I had to, you know...
I was, like, freaking out a little bit.
Be like, why is there only two holes?
Like...
God gave this GPU...
Thank God should have given this GPU more than two holes.
I...
Anyway...
I should stop.
Um...
So I had to take it out of the square hole...
And, like...
Unplug...
Please don't be lewd.
I'm just talking about the rubber plugs!
Don't you get it?
Help keep dust away!
What do you want me to say?
Like...
Like, how else do I... sorry, my English is becoming ESL even though English is my first language.
I went through a lot today.
But like, what do I say?
It's a dust plug!
Like, oh sorry, a dust cover?
Like, it's clogging up the hole!
There's no other words for it!
Anyway, as I was saying...
I, you know, I took out the dust... sorry, I removed the dust coverings of the hole.
Is that better?
Do you want this app to make changes to your... okay.
I don't know what's...
I had something pop up and I said yes to it.
I don't know.
I don't know what it was.
Anyway!
After...
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
No, my Discord notifications are going off too.
Okay.
After...
After, like, we did the whole... removing the dust coverings...
You know, I started plugging back in the...
I started plugging in back the...
Uh... monitors and everything.
Plugging all the USBs and all that stuff.
And then booting the PC on.
And then everything... all the features downloading and everything.
And then I was greeted by Windows 11.
I...
I was greeted... with Windows 11.
I've never, ever...
I've never... ever... used Windows 11 before.
So as a Windows 10 user...
For... X amount of years...
Being welcomed by Windows 11...
And seeing the fucking Windows key...
In the center...
was not it.
I was like...
I hate change.
Why is my Windows key...
In the center?
What is this freak of nature doing there?
Um...
And then, you know how like Windows 11 is like super minimalistic?
But I just...
Oh my gosh.
I just...
I can't...
It's so hard to deal with change sometimes.
Because I'm so used to seeing the same...
The same look...
For like...
Battle Explorers and everything.
So then I see like...
I just see like a square...
With like nothing.
With like nothing on it.
And I'm just like...
What the fuck is that?
Where are my bars?
Like...
Where are the...
Where are the bars?
To anything!
Why is it just a square?
Graphic design is my passion!
Like where is the stuff?
Anyway...
It was not a nice sight to see.
I was not...
Like I already went through a lot of change right now.
And then I have to see new...
More changes with Windows 11's interface.
Um...
So...
After that...
After you know...
Like being sad about Windows 11...
Where...
Where is my...
Exactly...
Where is my organized mess?
Where is my trash can?
I don't know what the fuck happened to my fucking trash can.
That was...
I was so sad.
I...
I was like...
Where the hell is the trash can?
Um...
Yes.
After all of that...
I had to go through the whole...
The sound system and everything.
But the one thing...
That fucked me up...
During all...
Before this...
Was that my Windows for some reason could not activate.
Like...
Hahaha...
I...
Where have I...
I couldn't activate my Windows.
I don't know what's going on.
So...
So I like messaged...
Hi, it...
It was like...
Hey, is this supposed to happen?
Am I supposed to...
Have like...
Like...
Am I supposed to not have...
Like pay my own Windows?
Hahaha...
I'm so confused.
I...
I was like...
I thought I have Windows.
Because I'm clearly in Windows 11.
But like...
You know how they're like...
Oh, if you don't...
And so I'm like...
How is it not...
How is it not activated?
Like...
I'm already in the system.
I don't understand.
Hahaha...
So...
Uh...
So I was like...
Hey...
Um...
What's going on?
And they're like...
That's weird.
Because it's supposed...
You're supposed to have it activated.
So they gave me like a new key.
And then they like...
They gave me a new key.
And I put it in.
And it gave me an error.
That was like...
Sorry.
Your hardware changed.
So like...
We do not accept this key.
Because it doesn't work with that key.
I'm like...
What does that mean?
What does that...
Hahaha...
I was just so confused.
I was like...
What does that mean?
What do you mean my hardware changed?
I just got the hardware.
Like...
I don't understand.
So...
Um...
So then...
So then I was like...
That key didn't work.
So then they gave me another key.
And...
And then I was like...
And they're like...
Okay.
You go to your PowerShell.
Whatever.
And then...
And then you put this number in.
And then I did it.
And it still didn't work.
So I was like...
I don't...
I don't know what's going on.
I was just like...
I just want to activate my windows.
I don't know.
Why...
Why can't the windows be activated?
I want to customize my windows.
Stop playing!
So, um...
So, like, I don't know.
They messaged me something new.
But then I was like, I'm just gonna stream.
I need like, therapy.
I mean, I shouldn't say therapy because that's fucked up.
I need my free therapy from my dragoons.
Like...
I need my... I need like, reassurance right now.
Like, I... You guys are like my emotional support animal right now.
Like, my emotional support pet.
I need like, some emotional support right now.
Dango, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I literally had the Windows change problem the other day.
There's a command in the command prompt.
You uninstall it and it will...
And re-enter the key.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, they want me to do something with like, command prompts.
So then I was just like, okay.
Okay, I'll do that after the stream.
I need like... I'm like...
I'm like mentally fucked up right now from all...
I couldn't say that.
But like, I'm... I'm...
Like, I'm at my limit.
This PC fucked me up.
I need my emotional support dragons right now.
Like, yeah.
I got mindbroken by my own PC.
Anyway.
So, we did...
Okay, I wrote a list of stuff that happened.
Just in case.
So...
So, yeah.
That's basically how it all went when it came...
Okay, so I have to install everything again.
Like, OBS.
Uh...
GoXLR.
Steam.
Um...
Almost like, everything back up again.
And inputting all my passwords and everything.
I don't even have majority of the scenes set up.
I just got the starting screen, ending screen...
And my chatting screen.
Um...
And that's like, everything I've set up so far.
Okay.
Uh...
Reaper, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Emotional support bucks.
Thank you.
Uh, Vapton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Built a PC a week ago and had the same problem.
Woke up one day and it activated.
It's cause keys are connected to Microsoft accounts.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, Vapton.
That's...
That's so fucking stupid.
Why?
What?
How...
So, like...
Do I just have to wait?
Like...
Hyatt bought me two...
Two product keys.
Like...
Wait, so like...
I just have to wait until they accept it?
Oh my...
Okay, well, I got two free...
Guys, I got two free window keys.
Okay.
Don't tell Hyatt this...
But like...
I...
I don't know if they're watching...
But like...
I freaked out...
Cause I was like...
Stream's about to start...
And I don't know what to do...
And like...
I...
I was like...
Really worried...
That like...
Because at that point...
Like...
It was more so of like...
Um...
My GoXLR wasn't work...
Like I...
My mic wasn't working...
So then I thought it was something to do with Windows...
So like...
Don't tell Hyatt...
But I also sort of spent $200...
And also...
Bought my own key...
Like...
I...
================================================ Vu That's what's utilizirding us here...
Now we're bonded for life...
You know my deep dark secret.
.
Now...
So now I have four key...xe.
You gonna have to keep that secret to your grave... 첿 thank you very much.
This was a super chat.
Thank you, thank you Key Fund.
Guys, it's okay.
It was 200 Canadian.
So that's like, you know, 100 American.
But yes, the key also did not work by the way.
So like, so like, I don't know.
Bill Gates is a little bit...
It's like now he's a little bit richer now.
So yay.
At least it goes to charity.
So...
So yes, I have four Windows 11 keys now chat.
Yay.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Darkblade, she be collecting all the keys like it's Kingdom Hearts.
Thank you for the super chat, Darkblade.
Thank you, thank you.
Ru, thank you for the super chat.
You figured it out.
You figured after using PC for so long, you become more tech savvy.
Guess that's not the case.
Here's some for the tech troubles.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But I've been using the same PC for like five years.
I've been coasting.
Guys, I've like used that PC until it literally died.
Like, I've been coasting so hard.
It like had like terminal disease.
And I didn't even try to like save it anymore.
I just let it keep going until like until it actually just died.
So, like what do you mean I should be more tech savvy?
I've been fucking coasting.
The moment it's at a good stage, I just don't care anymore about tech stuff.
Like I've reached my point.
I've reached my limit.
Yeah, I don't need a...
This is why I need a tech guy.
Anyway, so that was the story of...
That was the story of new PC.
And now that we're here, I think it's time that we...
Oh, Panzer, thank you for the 50 gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, Panzer.
Anyway, guys, now that we're here, I think it's time that we give it a real funeral.
Alright, let me...
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Okay.
So...
PC-kun has been with us for so long.
He's been there for like...
Since 2019.
And...
Oh my gosh.
I don't know if I can keep this...
Keep it together, guys.
And...
PC-kun has been here since 2019.
Oh shit, wait.
Sorry, PC-kun.
You're dead anyway already.
So like...
People gotta see when...
That they donated.
I'm sorry.
Give me a sec, PC-kun.
I'm...
Where are my alerts?
PC-kun, give me a sec.
I need to find my alerts so people can see that they donated.
Give me a sec.
You're already dead.
It's okay.
Alright, there we go.
Anyway, like I was saying...
PC-kun has been here for...
How many years?
20, 21, 22, 23...
Five years.
Sorry, I have to count for my fingers.
This is...
I'm sorry.
This is a problem.
And you've been there since the very beginning.
Before like anything really started.
Before like, you know...
Since I...
Before I went...
Went like...
Went big in content creation.
And...
You know, we've had lots of issues with you, PC-kun.
You know, with...
We...
You had a lot of surgeries over the years.
And...
You had so many operations.
Some of these parts inside you...
Used to be from the other PC before you.
The PC-kun senior.
Uh, yes.
I think that was also an issue, guys.
Regarding why PC-kun...
Like...
Fucked up in the way it did.
And just died like that.
Because it actually had some parts that...
Went from like even before his time.
So...
We had some transplants.
From like his previous generation.
So...
That could have been also a huge problem.
Um...
So he was...
He was a mess going in from the beginning.
Like I did not...
I did not like...
Give him like the pathway to success.
I was so fucking cheap.
I like Frankenstein parts together onto him.
So...
But...
Despite all of that...
You gave us five really good years, PC-kun.
For all of us.
From the Bark Knights...
To the Dragoons.
And like...
I mean...
PC...
He was a winner.
He went through so many tournaments.
And he got us that Sajam Slam 2 win.
Despite, you know...
Uh...
Despite we were going like five frames per second.
We were a fucking winner.
Uh...
Five glorious years.
In that five years...
During the three year mark...
We thought...
We thought you were gonna die.
In that five...
In...
I don't know if you guys remembered.
But in...
Year three...
Year three of his lifespan...
We had such a scary surgery that we had to do.
Do you guys remember that chat?
Where like...
He had to go through one of the scariest surgery at that time.
You guys remember that?
And...
And then you...
We laid you to rest.
Um...
Because you had to recover.
From...
From that surgery.
Do you guys...
Dragoons...
Do you remember that?
Uh...
We thought you wouldn't make it PC-kun.
We thought...
That's my bed!
What do you mean?
Is that a child bed?
I don't know.
It's a child bed.
Anyway...
In year three...
We thought we lost you.
And...
We took you to the...
We took you to the shop.
So...
And for your most scariest surgery.
And...
We thought we lost you.
Because you wouldn't run anything.
You crashed all my Apex games.
And like...
I couldn't boot up Fortnite.
We were so scared.
But...
After some...
After recovery from the...
From the...
From the surgery.
And like...
We put in new parts into you.
We put in a 4080.
We...
Oh wait.
No.
That's another surgery.
Sorry.
That's a surgery in the future.
What did we put in?
We put a new motherboard in you.
We got rid of the motherboard.
That came from PC-kun senior.
And we got you a new motherboard.
Because...
Joki has money then.
And she does now too.
But Joki was making so much money.
And she can finally...
Afford...
Better parts for you.
That you don't need to be Frankenstein anymore.
And then you recovered.
You got better.
And we thought you were gonna make it PC-kun.
We were...
We all cheered for you when you came back.
Israel thank you for the 10 gift ships.
Thank you.
And...
We thought you were gonna make it.
But then...
We didn't know what you had...
Was terminal.
That no amount of surgeries...
Was gonna save you.
But we were all a fool.
All of us thought...
That if we kept giving you new parts...
That we kept giving you new parts...
That we would just...
Frankensteining you.
That you'll just get better.
But...
Sadly...
That was not the case.
Because...
In another 2 years...
You started failing again.
And...
We couldn't even play Fortnite on you anymore.
We didn't know what to do.
So we took you back into the...
Hospital.
Back to the repair shop.
We took you back into the repair shop.
PC Koon.
We thought this time...
Maybe...
Maybe the second surgery...
The third or the third...
Also no sorry.
The third surgery...
You went through so many surgeries.
I've lost track.
We put you in there...
Back to back.
You were in the hospital...
For a week straight.
You had so many surgeries sent.
We even gave you a 4080.
We thought you would pull through.
Because when we took you back home after...
We could finally play Fortnite.
And the finals.
We were able...
To play Fortnite...
And the finals.
But...
It was just temporary.
Because whatever you had...
It spread again.
It didn't matter how many new parts we gave you PC Koon.
It didn't matter that you had a 4080.
Whatever that was inside you.
It kept coming back.
I was desperate.
I didn't want to let you go.
You've been here for five years PC Koon.
You were there since the beginning.
And you brought me all the way here.
We had to underclock it.
It was our last shot.
The doctors told me.
This was the last thing we can do.
Because you kept crashing.
You crashed again.
It was just one crash.
I thought it was just a fluke.
But then...
You kept crashing even more.
And then I got worried.
I was like...
It's just game crashes.
I don't have to worry about that.
But then...
You started blue screening.
And that's when I knew...
It was going to be a long time.
It was only a matter of time.
And...
We didn't have that much left together.
I thought...
Maybe the first blue screen...
It was a fluke.
You know PC Koon?
The very first blue screen we had...
It was a fluke.
But then you blue screened when we were just...
Playing off stream.
Well technically like they were streaming.
And you blue screened...
Four times.
In two hours.
That's when I knew...
I had to take you to the barn.
I had to take you to behind the barn.
Back to the farm upstate.
You were...
You were there...
For a long time PC Koon.
But...
Sadly...
Everything has to come to an end.
And I got sent a new free PC.
That might be a bit better than you.
I'll never say that while you're still alive.
Because technically I have to use you later.
And like him tonight.
So...
Do you care?
So you gotta live on just a little bit longer so...
Please!
So you gotta live on just a little bit longer, ヽ ノso...
They...
I'm sorry PC Koon.
I can't help.
This new PC...
Also has a 4080.
And all the parts... All the parts!
I don't know what's wrong with you.
There is no cure.
The doctors...
They said you had one year left to live.
But I extended your lifespan to five years, PC-kun.
But it's time.
You just...
You lived so long and saw so many victories, so many achievements.
But there was no cure to keep you on longer.
I can't keep frankensteining you anymore, PC-kun.
I don't know what is wrong.
I don't know what is wrong, PC-kun.
It's just not curable.
The doctors don't even know.
So we have to put you down.
Thank you for all the years you've given us.
I'll just say, PC-kun.
Just don't think of it, PC-kun.
Of me.
Like, I don't know what is wrong.
Like, replacing you with a younger, hotter model.
Like, it's not by choice, okay?
I just need you to know this, PC-kun.
It's not by choice that the newer PC happens to be younger and hotter and more expensive than you.
It's just...
It was just handed to me.
Like, why would I say no to free stuff?
Just know it wasn't by choice.
Anyway.
Thank you for everything you've done.
Do the dragoons have any final words to say to PC-kun, guys?
Do the dragoons have any final words to give us?
Don't worry, guys.
Do you guys have any final words?
Final words.
Hahaha!
07, guys.
Get NT, alright?!
It wasn't by choice, guys!
I told you!
It wasn't by choice!
It was just free!
It's been a long ride, PC-kun.
Now, before we give a moment of silence...
Before we give a moment of silence to PC-kun...
I just would like to say...
I would like to say something very important for them.
For them.
It is that...
We have a word from our sponsors.
So...
Anyway, I don't know if you guys know this, but my YouTube speaker is out now.
And it's actually crazy.
And... oh wait, sorry, let me turn off...
Let me...
Sorry, give me a sec.
Let me change the song real quick.
Alright.
Alright, anyway, before we...
Yeah, I need to have like a more upbeat song, by the way.
Give me a sec.
Alright, this is good.
Alright.
Oh my god, guys.
So...
Today, if you guys didn't know...
Today, the YouTube speaker just came out for pre-order.
And it's only for like four weeks, by the way.
So like after the four weeks is over...
Look, this funeral is not cheap.
After the...
After the four weeks is over, the figure is gone.
So make sure to pre-order now.
Before it's gone forever.
This is actually like my very...
This funeral is sponsored by YouTube.
So it's a...
This is my very first official Doki figure.
And I actually have like the prototype with me right now.
And it's really cool.
They sent it to me for free.
And everything.
So yeah, make sure...
It's so insane.
Like I checked it and like 500 of you guys already pre-ordered.
After it launched like four hours ago.
So like thank you guys.
Thank you, Dragos, for pre-ordering it.
And yeah, check it out.
I'm so happy that we have our first official figure.
Maybe more...
Many more to come in the future.
Let's hope.
Cross our fingers.
And hope that...
That we can get more amazing stuff in the future.
But yeah, huge shout out.
Huge shout out to...
To YouTube.
Wait, mod.
Where is the ad that you posted?
Can you repost the link and I'll pin it real quick?
Alright, let me pin this real quick.
Alright.
Alright, guys.
Alright, there you go.
I think that's good.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Okay, anyway.
Back to the...
Back to the funeral.
PC Koon would have wanted this!
Chat!
PC Koon would have wanted it!
I've been happy that I'm like making it right now.
Now...
Before we lower the casket...
For...
For PC Koon...
Let us...
Let us have a minute of silence...
For everybody.
Let's have a minute of silence for PC Koon and everybody.
Yes.
Well...
It's okay.
Now I have a hotter, newer version.
Hey!
Guys, I guess you guys never expected to...
expected a PC funeral, but here we are.
Don't disrespect him like that.
Oh my god, what a...
what a day, guys.
What a...
what a fucking day.
Oh yeah, we have PC will reading.
That PC had nothing.
I provided everything.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Yeah, that was basically...
my day.
My entire day.
I still have not downloaded...
I still haven't downloaded...
like everything yet.
And like I said, I need to fix my mic settings.
Like...
I know I sound different.
I'm sorry if I sound...
really different, guys.
But I hope...
I hope that like...
I can fix...
put it into my regular settings.
But tonight...
and I'm gonna take it...
I'm obviously gonna take it to the shop.
To like add another driver.
Uh... add another driver...
to this PC.
To my hotter...
newer trophy PC.
Uh... who's also younger.
Who's also...
younger...
from a good family too.
Um...
Sorry.
Install a new...
Get a new drive.
Get a new drive installed in there.
Get another SSD in there.
Because I don't like that it has only one SSD.
I feel like I'm gonna be using a lot of space.
So...
I'm gonna...
Uh...
Um...
Get another SSD added in there.
Just to fix it.
Uh...
Dude that's so... It's a PC!
Like what do you mean?
What the fuck do you mean?
It's literally a PC.
I'm just describing a PC.
Guys...
Uh...
And like...
I'm trying to think of what else I need to do.
I think... I know like I have to...
Oh yeah yeah yeah yeah.
I need to make sure I like...
save everything.
Like...
Uh... have all my correct settings and everything...
to establish.
But yeah.
Definitely gonna unplug this one...
tomorrow.
And take it to the shop.
Before my stream tomorrow.
The train.
Because like really I just need to install the SSD and everything.
So like... I'll plug back in.
I'll dig the grave out.
And then just plug it in and like...
I'll go like grave robbing...
later tonight.
Or tomorrow morning.
Actually do I grave rob tomorrow morning?
Or later tonight?
Maybe tomorrow?
Tomorrow morning.
So I'll go grave rob...
tomorrow morning.
And like...
dig through the carcass for...
uh... my mic settings.
The...
For the mic settings.
And then like you know...
put it back into the grave.
So I can put the mic... and then take my...
my new gal to the shop.
So I can...
My new gal wants a Gucci bag.
And I'm gonna get her that Gucci bag.
My new PC...
My younger...
more expensive...
She's a classy lady.
Okay?
I need to get her that Louis Vuitton bag.
And by Louis Vuitton bag...
I need to get her that SSD drive...
into her system.
And...
Get her... uh...
Get her all dolled up.
And...
I'm sorry...
I'm sorry I took that joke way too far.
I took that too far.
Um...
Uh... But yeah.
It's been a lot.
I think I only slept...
4 hours today.
Because I've just been like...
doing PC setup stuff.
I can't bel... I still can't...
believe it fit in the hole.
Like...
The triangle fit in the square hole.
Because that was literally my biggest...
problem.
And that's why it took...
so long.
Like I was...
stalling for so long.
Because I was trying to figure out what to do.
Because I was like... Okay maybe I'll just wait until I move.
You know?
Maybe I'll just wait until I move.
And then like buy a new desk.
That can fit this PC.
And then all it... And then it was only because...
like I forgot there's a side opening.
HAHAHAHAHA I forgot you can like...
put the PC in the side.
Like I kept thinking...
like I have to like slip it into the...
the pillars.
But I was like I can't slip it into the pillars.
It's a triangle.
This hole is a square.
Then I forgot there's literally a giant hole in the side.
That I could slide it in.
And this PC...
I spent in a box for a month.
And then just out there for another month.
Because I literally couldn't do shapes.
Like I couldn't...
I literally couldn't like figure out shapes.
And like spatial awareness.
That like it was going to fit.
It was only because I...
My other PC...
My PC-kun was literally...
dead.
Like the carcass was just there in the open.
That I had to try something.
Look I'm 2D.
I can't think in 3D.
Chat.
This is the issue.
I can't think in 3D.
If I'm 2D.
You can't blame that on me.
I don't think in three dimensionals.
What a fucking...
wild ride.
Well...
I think that's really it.
That's really it.
We celebrated.
We celebrated our new PC.
And held a funeral.
Two in one special.
Guys.
I hope you guys enjoyed hanging out with me today.
Uh...
I had a great time.
Just you know...
Just chilling with chat.
Um...
And having you guys there.
Support dragoons.
Uh...
During the rough time.
Trying to set everything up.
So it was really...
It was great.
I had a great time guys.
I hope you guys had a...
Well not...
I hope you guys didn't have a great time at the funeral.
But like I hope you guys had a general good time.
Not the funeral part.
But like you know.
Everything else before and after the funeral.
I'm gonna call it here everybody.
Thank you all for the Akasupas too.
Chat.
I really appreciate it.
Uh...
Thank you to our real one.
He will be a missed.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you for the memories PC-kun.
Uh...
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
But yeah.
I told you guys.
I told you guys I have the new PC set up.
Before the stream today.
Yay!
Anyway guys.
As always everybody stay hydrated.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.